jacques wigley strolls through the
streets of paris
he admires the graffiti on the walls of
his neighborhood
contemporary street artists work in
public spaces as he did four or five
decades ago but in a very different way
he worked with ordinary advertising
posters
laceration is an act of liberation
because the commercial smile wants to
direct you towards a product
politicians want to instruct you
so laceration is a somewhat anarchist
gesture
as a young man biglay would rip ads from
the walls often tearing through several
layers and then frame the results
although people didn't really understand
what he was doing
he was questioned by the police but
never charged
today works by jacques vigley and his
friends raymond ah and francois dufresne
hang in major art museums around the
world
they're the subject of a show at the
sheern gallery in frankfurt documents of
a city's collective consciousness
with all these torn posters jacques
vigley recorded the place and the date
you could say he had a topography of the
city in mind
which is reflected in these posters
another artist who practiced decollage
using fragments of posters ripped off
walls was mimo rotella in rome who
composed works with strips of posters in
a critical reworking of consumerist
motifs
german artist vol fostel worked with
overtly political motifs big lay took a
purely aesthetic approach
i am an observer
i'm interested in what happens
i can take a poster that is leftist or
rightist
without myself tending to the left or to
the right
i wanted to be the painter of my epoch
and the best way of becoming that was to
take the decor of the street
in
a two 1949 a half meters long freeze
for them art was made by all not by one
at his studio in paris biglay has lots
of old material he'd still like to frame
he practiced epheshisma longer than
anyone else for decades in fact
in the 1990s he had to go to cities such
as marseille where such posters could
still be found
in their in other cities they were gone
nowadays with billboards and digital
media poster culture has been
transformed
so what the heirs of afashi's art do is
entirely different
the art of jacques bigley also developed
in the late 1960s he created what he
called a socio-political alphabet
each letter becomes a symbol
he has written entire texts using this
system
these works are now also museum pieces
still he does not really see himself as
a precursor of present-day graffiti art
i did the opposite back then
i took from the street and took it into
the studio
while they work in the street
vigne no longer rips posters off walls
nor does he have to his work is a
successful reflection of four decades of
city life